بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله
وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين واشهد ان لا اله
الا الله وحده لا شريك له هو يتولى
الصالحين واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين اما بعد
قراءتنا موصوله
لمختصر زاد المعاد من هدي خير العباد لابن
القيم رحمه الله
وهذا الاختصار
اختصار مشهور معروف
وهو
اختصار الشيخ محمد ابن عبد الله التميمي
رحمه الله تعالى
وهو اشهر المختصرات
والجيد في هذا الاختصار لمن اراد ان
يقتنيه
فانه قد
حذف منه
جميع المناقشات التي يناقشها ابن القيم
رحمه الله
وردود العلماء على بعض واقوال في الاسانيد
اسانيد الحديث وتعليلات وهذه الامور التي
لا ينتفع بها الا
اصحاب التخصص
طلاب العلم والعلماء
وابقى على جميع ما جاء فيه اقوال الرسول
صلى الله عليه وسلم واحواله
وكذلك الاحاديث وجميع ما كان من صلب
موضوع الكتاب من صلب موضوع الكتاب جزاك
الله خير
هو اختصار جيد وثم اختصارات اخرى
وتهاذيب لهذا الكتاب القيم
وبعض من هذب هذا الكتاب
رام ان
يرتب الكتاب لان الكتاب غير مرتب على
طريقه الكتب
الفقهيه الموضوعه في هذا الباب فيها
تقديم وتاخير وهو مرتب ترتيبا يعني
ترتيب عابر وذلك لان ابن القيم رحمه الله
الف هذا الكتاب من
ذهنه واللفه
بعفو الخاطر وما استحضره في مسيرته
من الى مكه المكرمه للحج
واكمل هذا الكتاب
واكمل تسويد هذا الكتاب
دون ان يكون له مراجع
والذي يقرا هذا الكتاب
على وضعه الاول
الذي وضعه عليه ابن القيم رحمه الله
فانك
تشعر والله اعلم ان نيته
اختلفت في اثناء الكتاب الظاهر انه اراد
فقط ان يملي بعض شمائل النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم وبعض الامور التي هي
تكون كالمذكره لاحواله صلى الله عليه وسلم
فافتتح الكتاب باسماء دوابه واسماء نسائه
واسماء
مؤذنيه واسماء حراسه وهكذا واستمر ثم كانه
توسعت عنده الفكره
فابتدا يملي جميع ما
رجحه
من احوال النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
النوم وفي العاده
ووصفه وكذلك في سنته وفي الوحي
واستمر على ذلك
وكتاب الطب
كتاب الطب الذي هو في العاده المجلد
الرابع
فيه ترتيب جيد
ترتيب حتى على حروف
مرتب هذا الكتاب ترتيبا مثل ترتيب
القواميس
وهذا يظهر منه انه رجع رحمه الله الى
مكتبته وابتدا فيه وشرع في ترتيب هذا
الكتاب فاصبح الكتاب
سهل المنال يستطيع اي واحد عنده
شيء يريد ان ينظره من احوال طبيه
فمثلا اذا عنده حمى ينظر في حرف حاء ويجد
علاج النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم في الحمى
وكذلك
جميع هذه الاحوال مثل القاموس مرتب هذا
ظاهر منه انه كان لما رجع يعني اول ثلث
مجلدات والسيره المختصره من ذهنه ثم بعد
ذلك
اكمل الكتاب في
موطنه وفي مكتبته لانه مرتب ترتيبا متقنا
وعلى اي حال فكثيرا ما نجد
هذا الكتاب
مطبوعا دون بقيه
مجلداته يعني تجد كتاب الطب النبوي هكذا
مسمى الطب النبوي ماشي
لابن القيم رحمه الله هذا الكتاب
يبتاع وطبع وحقق ونقح
منفردا عن بقيه زاد المعاد فهو ليس كتابا
مستقلا الفه ابن القيم رحمه الله وانما هو
ماخوذ من زاد المعاد وهذا يحصل كثيرا اذا
ابدع عالم ما في مساله معينه في اثناء
كتاب متوسع له فانك تجد ان العلماء يطبعون
هذا الكتاب منفردا
مثل
مثل كتاب قصص الانبياء لابن كثير رحمه
الله كتاب مشهور معروف منتشر هذا الكتاب
قصص الانبياء لابن القيم رحمه الله هو
المجلد الاول من تاريخه البدايه والنهايه
كذلك النهايه في الفتن والملاحم
لابن كثير رحمه الله منتشر وهذا الكتاب هو
الجزء السادس عشر من كتاب البدايه
والنهايه وهكذا العلماء يفعلون هذا وجزاهم
الله خيرا
على كل حال قد تقدم الكلام ووصلنا الى
ذكر المؤلف رحمه الله
للبيعه الثانيه بيعه العقبه الثانيه
وابتداء التحرك الى المدينه يقول ابن
القيم رحمه الله
فعند هذه البيعه بيعه العقبه
ان النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
قيل له قال له بعض الانصار يا رسول الله
على ما تبايعه نبايعك قال على السمع
والطاعه في النشاط والكسل وعلى النفقه في
العسر واليسر وعلى الامر بالمعروف والنهي
عن المنكر وعلى ان تقوموا في الله لا
تاخذكم فيه لومه لائم وعلى ان تنصروني اذا
قدمت عليكم وتمنعوني مما تمنعون منه
انفسكم وازواجكم وابناءكم ولكم الجنه
فقمنا نبايعه فاخذ بيده اسعد بن زراره
فقال رويدا يا اهل يثرب انا لم نضرب اليه
اكباد المطي الا ونحن نعلم انه رسول الله
وان اخراجه اليوم مفارقه العرب كافه
وان تعضكم السيوف
فاما تصبرون على ذلك فخذوه واجركم على
الله
واما تخافون من انفسكم خيفه فذروه فهو
اعذر لكم عند الله
فقالوا امط عنا يدك فوالله لا نذر هذه
البيعه ولا نستقيلها
فقمنا اليه رجلا رجلا فاخذ علينا يعطينا
بذلك الجنه صلى الله عليه وسلم يقول ابن
القيم ثم انصرفوا الى المدينه
وبعث معهم رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
ابن ام مكتوم ومصعب ابن عمير يعلمان
القران
وابن امي مكتوب عبد الله بن ام مكتوم
معروف هو كان احد
مؤذني رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم في
المدينه
وهو الحديث المشهور المعروف بين الناس
لا تمسكوا عن الطعام والشراب
لاذان بلال فانه يؤذن بالليل وكان ابن ام
مكتوم رضي الله عنه يجلس على سطح البيت هو
ضرير يعني ما يبصر
فيجلس على سقف البيت قبيل الفجر
فاذا نباه الماره الناس متجهين الى الصلاه
اذا نبهوه على دخول الوقت
وبزوغ الفجر فانه يقوم ويؤذن
وهذا يدل على ما جاء في كلام الفقهاء
من كلام الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم في
اننا في اننا
نؤخر
السحور السحور يؤخر
وكان النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم يؤخره الى
اذاني ابن ام مكتوم كذلك ابن ام مكتوم رضي
الله عنه كان يؤن الصلاه نيابه عن النبي
صلى الله عليه وسلم اذا خرج فيه غزاه او
خرج لحاجه فانه
قد يجعل ابن ام مكتوم
اميرا او وكيلا له على المدينه ومن جراء
ذلك يكون يؤم الصلوات
فالنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم بعث مع هؤلاء
الانصار الذين بايعوه
ابن ام مكتوم ومصعب ابن عمير يعلمان
القران ويدعوان الى الله فنزل على اسعد بن
زراره وكان مصعب ابن عمير يامهم وجمع بهم
لما بلغوا اربعين فاسلم على يديهما بشر
كثير منهم اسيد بن حدير وسعد بن معاذ
واسلم باسلامهما يومئذ جميع بني عبد
الاشهل الا القصير فتاخر اسلامه الى يوم
احد فاسلم حينئذ
وقاتل حتى قتل ولم يسجد لله سجده يعني
اسلم في اثناء الغزوه
في اثناء المعركه اسلم
وقاتل واستشهد رضي الله عنه فهو المعروف
بالصحابي الذي
قتل واستشهد ودخل الجنه ولم يسجد لله سجده
رضي الله عنه واسيد بن حضير هو الصحابي
الجليل
المجاهد المعروف بكثره
مشاركته في الغزو وفي الفتوحات
وكذلك سعد بن معاذ هو الذي قال فيه النبي
صلى الله عليه وسلم
اهتز له عرش الرحمن يوم مات تعظيما لشانه
فهذا القصيرم تاخر اسلامه الى يوم احد
فاسلم حينئذ وقاتل حتى قتل ولم يسجد لله
سجده فقال رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
عمل قليل واجر كثير
وكثر الاسلام في المدينه وظهر
ثم رجع مصعب الى مكه
ووافى الموسم ذاك العام خلق كثير من
الانصار من المسلمين والمشركين
فكان المسلمين كثر في المدينه والجميع
يذهب الى الحج في الموسم
للتجاره ولحج بيت الله كما كانت عاده
المشركين من قبل وهذه من بقايا دين
ابراهيم عليه السلام
فكانوا يحجون ففي الموسم
ذهب الى الحج وذهب الى مكه للقاء النبي
صلى الله عليه وسلم من اسلم من الانصار
ومن لم يسلم ويريد ان يرى يرى هذا النبي
قبل ان يسلم يعني
في ذهنه انه بده يلتقي بهذا النبي وينظر
ما هذا الاسلام الذي
ظهر
قال وزعيم القوم البرائب المعرور فكانت
بيعه العقبه وكان اول من بايعه البرائب
المعرور وكانت له اليد البيضاء اذ اكد
العقد وبادر اليه واختار رسول الله صلى
الله عليه وسلم منهم تلك الليله اثني عشر
نقيبا اثني عشر نقيبا يعني النقيب هو الذي
يكون كالامير فلما تمت البيعه استاذنوه
على ان يميلوا على اهل منى باسيافهم فلم
ياذن لهم
وصرخ الشيطان على العقبه بابعد صوت سمع يا
اهل يا اهل الجباجب هل لكم في محمد
والصبا معه قد اجتمعوا على حربكم فقال
رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم هذا ازب
العقبه اما والله يا عدو الله لا اتفرغن
لك فهو كان يبايع وكان يبايعهم ويبايعونه
سرا
فالشيطان راى هذا الامر فصرخ
لما يقول
صرخ الشيطان هل هو يعني الشيطان بمعنى
ابليس ولا الشيطان بمعنى شيطان ذلك المكان
غير ظاهر لكن
الذي نعلم انه من الجن من الشياطين صرخ
باهل مكه من المشركين
من اجل ان يميلوا على هؤلاء الانصار
وهؤلاء المسلمين
ويحدث
الحرب والقاتل بينهم ويحدث الفتنه
فالنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم قال اما والله
يا عدو الله لا اتفرغن لك
ثم امرهم ان ينفضوا الى رحالهم فلما
اصبحوا غدت عليهم اشراف قريش
فقالوا بلغنا انكم لقيتم صاحبنا البارحه
وواعدتموه ان تبايعوه على حربنا
وان الله ما حي من العرب ابغض الينا من ان
تنشا بيننا وبينه الحرب منكم يعني احنا
بيننا علاقات طيبه علاقات تجاريه بيننا
الحلف الحلفاء وهكذا
احنا انتو اخر ناس بدنا نقاتلهم يعني
الانصار بين علاقه طيبه وانتم اذا اويتم
محمدا صلى الله عليه وسلم فان ذلك يسبب
الحرب
فيريدون ان
يميلوا عليهم بنوع من السياسه
وهذا فيه تهديد تهديد يعني مستور
كانهم يقولون
يعني احنا جماعه بنحبكم
وحابين انه ما يكون في بيننا حرب
وبينا علاقات طيبه
لكن المفهوم من الكلام هذه العلاقات تنتهي
ويكون بيننا الحرب وكذلك ينتهي
جميع المصالح التي بيننا وبينكم
قالوا ويم الله
وايم الله يعني كانه
يقسم ونوع من القسم
ماء حي من العرب حي يعني قبيله من العرب
ابغض الينا من ان تنشب بيننا وبينه الحرب
منكم
فانبعث من هناك من المشركين يحلفون بالله
ما كان هذا
يعني المشركون من الانصار الذين لم يكونوا
فيه البيعه ما يدرون فهم قاموا قالوا هذا
الكلام ما حصل لانه ما عندهم خبر
وجعل ابن ابي يقول هذا باطل وما كان قومي
ليفتاتوا علي بمثل هذا لو كنت بيثرب ما
صنع قومي هذا حتى يؤامروني
ابن
ابي هو عبد الله ابن ابي ابن تلول
ابن ابي ابوه اسمه ابي
وامه سلول وهو من
وهذا شيء نادر يعني في انساب العرب ان
ينسب
احد الى امه لكن انتشر هذا عنه وكان يقال
له عبد الله بن ابي ابن سلول
عبد الله بن ابي هو راس المنافقين
وهو مذكور في القران بصفته
في اكثر من موضع
من هذه المواضع ولا ان سالتهم لا يقولن
انما كنا نخوض ونلعب قل ابي الله واياته
ورسوله كنتم تستهزئون لا تعتذروا قد كفرتم
بعد ايمانكم هذا في عبد الله بن ابي
واصحابه وكذلك قوله تعالى
والذي تولى كبره منهم في حادثه الافك هو
الذي تولى كبره يعني كان هو السبب في اكثر
واعظم نصيب من هذا الافتراء الذي كان على
عائشه رضي الله عنها عبد الله بن ابي
ما الذي دفعه الى هذا الحقد
ولم
يترك اي مجالا
يستطيع فيه ان يؤذي النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم
اذاه اذاه اذاه مده طويله حتى لما مات
جاء ابنه وابنه كان مسلما صحابيا
فجاء النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم وذكر ان
اباه ليس له كفن
فالنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم اعطى ابنه ثوبه
باء كان كفا راس المنافقين ثوب النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم
واراد ان يستغفر له بعد كل هذه الاذيه
والرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم لا يريد احدا
يدخل النار
فاراد ان يستغفر له فمنعه الله سبحانه
وتعالى
فقال استغفر لهم او لا تستغفر لهم ان
تستغفر لهم سبعين مره
لن يغفر الله له
هذا نزل هذه الايه نزلت في عبد الله بن
ابي بن سلول ومن كان على شاكلته من
المنافقين هو راس المنافقين في المدينه
ما الذي حمله على هذا
الذي حمله على هذا
الحسد
عبد الله بن ابي كان زعيم الانصار
او سوى الخزرج كان
لا مرتبه
كعب عالي في قومه كان من الاسياد
ولم يبقى عليهم الا ان يتوجوه
يعني كاد ان يكون ملك ملكا
لكن لما قدم النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
حس بان البساط قد انسحب من تحت قدميه
وانصرف الناس الى رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم
وكان له السعدد الاعظم
عبد الله بن ابي بن سلول
يعني حسده وحقد عليه من اجل هذا
وهذا من جهله
لان الانبياء لا ياتون
للاخذ من منازل الناس
الياتون
ويعظمون العظماء من الناس
ولا
يستحقروهم يعني مثلا
فرعون موسى عليه السلام ما جاء وقال انت
الان من اليوم وطالع مش فرعون انا بكون
الزعيم الاكبر هنا لا تبقى الملك بين
الناس لكن تسلم وتصدر عنه
الوحي وحي الله سبحانه وتعالى
والعظيم في قومه يبقى كذلك
وكذلك الانبياء
فهم ياتون بهذا لكن عبد الله بن ابي
شعر بان النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم اخذ منه
هذه المنزله
حقد عليه
فاثنى عمره في
اذيه النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم حتى مات
وسبحان الله الله عز وجل
كلما يذكر المنافقين في القران
يذكرهم بصفاتهم
مثل واذا لقوا الذين امنوا قالوا امنا
واذا خلوا الى شياطينهم قالوا انا معكم
وهلم جره اي مكان
نجد
للمنافقين ذكر من كتاب الله
فان اسم عبد الله بن ابي يكون في سبب
النزول دائما
ذيته كانت بالغه الغايه لرسول الله صلى
الله عليه وسلم
اذاه وشن عليه
حربا غير مباشر
وهو من ساهم في مسجد الضرار وهو من
كان يستهزئ بالنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
واصحابه وهو الذي
حاول ان
حاول ان يضعف المسلمين وشوكه المسلمين في
غزوه احد
يعني في غزوه احد
لما وصلوا
الى المعركه عبد الله بن ابي امره قومه ان
ينصرفوا
فانصرفوا وبعد النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
ما رجع من احد قالوا لو كنا نعلم قتالا
لاتبعناكم
هذه ايضا في عبد الله بن ابي
وهكذا يفعل هذه الاشياء
اذيه للنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم والدافع له
ماذا الحقد
زلمه عنده غيره
زعلان
ليش هذا الذي جاء يكون فوقي وليش الناس
انصرفت ابصارهم عني
وذهب
ذهنهم
وانصب على رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
والنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم يقول في مثل
هذا
يقول ما ذئباني جائعان ارسل في غنم
بافسد لها من حرص المرء على الجاه والمال
لدينه
كان الذي يطلب الجاه
او يطلب المال
وهذا الطلب يكون خارج
الحدود الشرعيه
هذا يهلك دينه اهلاكا في هذا السبيل
مثل الذئب الجائع الذي ارسل في غنم
هذا جعان وادخل وبصير ياخذ من كل مكان
بل المثل هنا ان
الغنم دين الانسان
مثل ايش صلاه زكاه احسانه
الخصال الحسنه
وهذا الذئب الجائع ويقول ما ذئبان جائعان
يعني
حرص طلب المال وطلب الجاه
ولا يهمه الا هذا ويقدم هذا الطلب على
دينه فان دينه
لا يبقى منه باقيه
وهذا الذي كان من عبد الله بن ابي
وسبحان الله يعني افنى بقيه عمره في اذيه
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
والله عز وجل يقول والله يستهزئ بهم
ويمدهم
انما نحن مستهزئون الله يستهزئ بهم هكذا
في الايه
اي
خساره
اعظم
من ان تدفن
في ثوب عدوك
هو متخذ الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم عدوه
الاكبر
فلما مات
جعل الله سبحانه وتعالى كفنا
جيفته
كافا عدوه الاكبر من الذي غلب
وهذا من عجيب حكمه الله سبحانه وتعالى
على كل حال عبد الله بن ابي ما اسلم الا
بعد معركه بدر
لان معركه بدر
كانت بدايه
قوه وظهور قوه الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
والمسلمين
ما ظنوا العرب كلها تنظر الى غزوه بدر
ولا يظن احد
ان المسلمين
سيغلبون لكن غلبوا وانتصروا
ومن تمام الغلبه ان النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم
كان يبقى في ساحه المعركه بعد المعركه
ويقيم هناك اياما
وهذا فيه ايش ارغام للعدو
فلما رات العرب هذا دخلوا في الاسلام
افواجا منهم الصادقون ومنهم
الكاذبون المنافقون فالمنافقون دخلوا في
الاسلام بعد
غزوه بدر وكان من اوائلهم عبد الله بن ابي
بن سلول
ومن اعظم ما جاء في حق عبد الله بن ابي بن
سلول ان المنافقين في الدرك الاسفل من
النار
والعياذ بالله
قال ابو هريره تفسيرا لهذه الايه يقول
يكونون في الدرك الاسفل من النار في
توابيت
من حديد
وغلق عليهم والعياذ بالله
يؤتى باحدهم تابوت من حديد ويوضع في هذا
التابوت ويكون
اسفل سافلين والعياذ بالله وهذه الايه
ايضا ذكر
ذكر اهل التفسير عبد الله بن ابي في اسباب
نزول هذه الايه
هو راس المنافقين
اذا نظرنا الى القران
وتتبعنا كل ايه فيها ذكر للمنافقين
فيها ذكر اذيه المنافقين
وفيها ذكر حرب المنافقين
على الاسلام
نجد ان هذه الايات كثيره جدا
اليس كذلك
يعني الله عز وجل يذكر في سوره البقره
يستفتح كلامه وكتابه بخمس ايات في
المؤمنين
وايتين في الكفار ثم اطنب ببضع عشره ايه
في المنافقين واوصافهم
وحذر منهم
وقال الله تعالى هم
العدو فاحذرون هم العدو كانه لا عدو
غيره
فاذا انا ذكرت هذه الايات كلها نستكثرها
يتصور الانسان
ان المنافقين كانوا
كثره كافره
في العهد النبوي
لكن النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم يقول في
صحيح مسلم
منافقوا امتي
اثنا عشر رجلا
كل هذا في ايش 12 واحد
12 واحد سببوا كل هذه المصائب التي المت
بالمسلمين طبعا المقصود باثنا عشر رجل
رجلا 12 رجلا يعني رؤوس المنافقين والذين
هم في النار ولا يقبل الله سبحانه وتعالى
منهم
اي عذر ولا اي اعتذار
وكان ثم اقوام اضعف في النفاق منهم من تاب
الله سبحانه وتعالى عليه
ومنهم من لم يتوا بالله سبحانه وتعالى
عليه ولكن راس المنافقين رؤساء المنافقين
عظماء المنافقين كانوا ايش اثني عشر رجلا
كل هالمصائب من 12 واحد
العياذ بالله
وهذا يدل على
عظمه مصيبه النفاق والمنافقين
لكانوا بيننا
فانهم يفسدون
وهم يكونون معوله الشيطان
ليهدم بهم الاسلام من الداخل
باللغه الحديثه يسمونه ماذا الطابور
الخامس هذول يكونوا بين المسلمين ويفسدوا
كل هذا الفساد الذي وقع من 12 رجلا في
اعظم جيل جيل الصحابه
كانوا احرى الناس
بالا
يؤذوا بهؤلاء
هذه رابعه رابعه
الله المستعان
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم ذكر ان
ان سبيل الشيطان الوحيد
في ادخال شروره
بين المسلمين
وسلخ المسلمين عن دينهم
هم المنافقون جاء في السنن وحديث معروف
يقول النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
ايس الشيطان
ان يعبده المصلون في جزيره العرب
ولكن بالتحريش بينهم
يعني الشيطان لما راى قوه المسلمين قوه
اخوتهم وقوه اخذهم بالكتاب بكتاب الله
وبالوحي وقوه تصديقهم وشده
جهادهم
يائسه ان يعبده المصلون يعني المسلمون في
جزيره العرب يائس قال
ذهبت ذهب ملكي لا يعود كما كان
لكن قال ايش قال ولكن بالتحريش بينهم
هذا التحريش الذي يكون بينهم من قبل
المنافقين الذين هم
منافقون تماما بمعنى انهم يبطنون الكفر
ويظهرون الاسلام او حالهم حال المنافقين
من الكذب
ومخالفه الوعد
نقض العهد
والخيانه
والغيبه والنميمه بين المسلمين
وتتبع عورات المسلمين هذا نفاق
صاحبه لا يكون منافقا
كاملا نفاق ولكن له احوال من احوال
المنافقين هذه الاحوال كلها احوال النفاق
في الاسلام
فهذا هو التحريش الذي
طمع الشيطان في ان يعيد عباده الاصنام على
المسلمين من هذا السبيل والعياذ بالله
يقول وجعل ابن ابي يقول هذا باطل يعني مش
ممكن انه قومي بايعوا احدا وانا موجود انا
قومي يراجعوني في كل شيء مش ممكن هذا صار
فقالوا ابن ابي هذا باطل وما كان قومي
ليفتاتوا علي بمثل هذا
لو كنت بيثرب ما صنع قومي هذا حتى
يؤامروني ياخذوا رايي في هذا الامر ويطلب
الاذن على هذا الشيء
كلامه
شبيه جدا بكلام مين فرعون
قال امنتم به قبل ان اذن لكم
نفس الكلام يعني
فرجعت قريش ورحل البراء الى بطني ياجج
وتلاحق اصحابه من المسلمين
وطلبتهم قريش فادركوا سعد بن عباده فجعلوا
يضربونه حتى ادخلوه مكه
فجاء مطعم ابن عدي والحارث ابن حرب بن
اميه
فخلصاه منهم وتشاورت الانصار حين فقدوه ان
ان يكرروا اليه يعني يرجع اليه فاذا هو قد
طلع عليهم فرحلوا جميعا
واذن رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
للمسلمين في الهجره الى المدينه
فبادر الناس لاحظوا الكلام الان
احنا ذكرنا ان
التاريخ الاسلامي تاريخ الشرعي
اجمع عليه الصحابه في عهد مين في عهد عمر
بن الخطاب رضي الله عنه
وتشاوروا على ما يبتدئون تاريخهم لان
التاريخ كل التاريخ يبتدا من ماذا من شيء
كبير
ولاده احد او
واقعه وقعت او حرب او ما شابه ذلك كل
التاريخ لا بد ان يبتدئ من يوم معروف
مشهود
كان تاريخ المشركين من مكه تاريخه ماشي
على ايش وقعت الفيل
ذلك تجد الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم ولد
فيه عامل في وقيل بعد سنتين وقيل قبل هذا
كله لان هذه الواقعه كانت عظيمه
وما ارادوا ان يبتدئوا
التاريخ بعض الصحابه قال من مولد الرسول
صلى الله عليه وسلم وبعضهم قال من
اول نزول الوحي عليه وبعضهم قال من اول
اظهار الدعوه
وبعضهم قال وبعضهم قال الى ان استقر رايهم
على هجره الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم لان
هذه الهجره كانت ايش بدايه ظهور الاسلام
فاجمع على الهجره الرسول صلى الله عليه
وسلم هاجر في شهر ربيع
ما هاجر في محرم لكن اول شهر في شهور
الهجريه شهر محرم
لماذا لان الهجره
بدات
وتحرك المسلمون للهجره في شهر ايش محرم
يعني صار هذه هذه البيعه كانت في ذي الحجه
والشهر الذي يليه شهر محرم ابتدا
المسلمون يتحركون ويتجهون الى المدينه
وابتدا النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم بالتخطيط
اليها فكان هذا في محرم لذلك اختير محرم
ان يكون
الشهر الاول
في التاريخ الهجري
فيقول ابن القيم واذن رسول الله صلى الله
عليه وسلم في الهجره الى المدينه فبادر
الناس فكان اول من خرج اليها ابو سلمه
وامراته
ولكنها حبست عنه سنه وحيل بينها وبين
ولدها ثم خرجت بعد بعد بولدها الى المدينه
وشيعها عثمان بن ابي طلحه رضي الله عنه
هذا نكتفي بهذا القدر والله اعلم وصلى
الله وسلم على نبينا محمد وعلى اله
واصحابه اجمعين
الله اكبر الله اكبر